but then again i find it absolutely
hilarious that you gave black butler
a 5. honestly
and you gave black butler season 2
specials a three
honestly i still say i still would
really yeah
everyone i i made it no i didn't i would
not try and hide it that i did not like
the show your life is a lie i see wwe
fans he was never a black baller he was
never a black baller
you gave monica to second season at 10.
i definitely suffered as a as a team
getting into anime
like i was heavily influenced by what
everyone else was i mean i grew up
yeah i am a liar second season is
definitely getting these them on a
guttery at ten as well
this is definitely the case of teenage
connor saw that everyone was saying the
show was good that i didn't understand
so i'm just gonna put it yeah i can tell
because you gave uh
mirai nikki a nine did you actually i
think i really enjoyed that show when i
watched it oh man
seven years ago so i was i thought you
just said how old was i when i was 14
i was 17 yeah 17 when i made this list
yeah this sounds about right for 17 year
old connor like dead man wonderland and
eight yeah that checks out
okay okay you gave monster a seven
um what what i'm gonna have to
[Music]
to pick it back up download dropped it
about yeah about 10 episodes in because
the [ __ ]
didn't [ __ ] move but then actually
but then you when you watch it and
you're like oh wait [ __ ] it's good
holy [ __ ] nevermind oh [ __ ] oh hold on
hold on
but now like i gave cowboy seven as well
which honestly
you know maybe it's an a but it's it's
honestly it's not 10 or not there are
some shows on here that i'm surprised
you watched at all like zombie loan
zombie loan i have no idea why i watched
that show but i remember being angry
that i watched that [ __ ]
i remember being like mad that i wasted
my time watching the only reason why i
watched zombie alone was because i heard
it was a peach pit
show and i was like i like peach pits
i gave school days of one though yeah i
see that i see that
you finished sunday without god yeah
yeah i noticed that
i haven't finished that i finished it
but i definitely did not give it a 7.
and he gave me the seven which one
sunday without god exactly
that's that's that's the point i'm
trying to make something
yeah with the show oh yeah i
i can actually tell you the exact time i
watched that i remember very very when i
watched that so
that when i first got into anime i was
watching it on like the shitty like
pirate sites figuring out what the [ __ ]
was going on yeah i
accidentally watched full metal
alchemist twice not realizing like what
the [ __ ] i was doing
and then i finally got a free trial for
crunchyroll
and so i watched as much anime as i
could for the 48 hours right
and that was one of them we're not
sponsored by crunchyroll
actually that was that was one of the
ones that i i watched and that was
zombie alone one of them as well
no no no no that was before so i
remember that was probably the first
ever 12 episode show i watched on
crunchyroll i think right right
it's some of this just doesn't make
sense you watched outbreak company
yeah i did yeah that's that's
and gave it a nine yeah all three
seasons i actually really liked it
i really liked it i liked it as well
that just that just doesn't seem
surprising to me
i'm just like my jaws on the floor
because if you were to tell me that
conor finishes show and lights i'm just
like
what is this wait you also give
higarashi an eight uh season one
yeah uh i think i would take that back
what would you give it now
i watched it dubbed so maybe a four like
like i'm looking i'm looking at some of
this and i'm just like is this
me yeah right like he gave devlius a
part-timer
a [ __ ] 10. i love that i love dude
that's really good that is really good
if you actually look at my account my
profile picture is devil's apartment
i loved i loved devil as a part-timer